We'll now adjourn for a second and begin
our budget workshop on the Housing Department. Thank you.
This time I'd like to welcome Director Keith Bottom and Ms. Tamika Jones
to provide the Houston Housing Department budget presentation.
Good afternoon. Good afternoon.
Joining me today is my assistant
director and Chief Financial Officer, Ms. Tamika Jones.
If we go through the next slide,
we are a department of acronyms. So here's a list
of all the acronyms that we use. So we just wanted to provide
you with that. If you go to the next slide, please.
For the General Fund, we are probably the smallest budget you
will see. At this budget hearing. We are projected
to get $411,604
representing FTEs of 0.3.
That 0.3 is represented by personnel.
And you'll see the FY 23 budget of 135,493,
which is the three which is part of my salary
as well as employee exit costs,
as benefit termination pay and workers compensation.
And then the other side of that chart, you'll see the other services and
charges which represent $276,111
which covers janitorial, rent and other miscellaneous
chargebacks. Next slide.
Let me get a little closer.
All right. Is that better? All right. Thank you.
If you go to that slide, you'll see all of department programming.
You'll see single family home repair and reconstruction.
Single family new construction, home buyer assistance and
home buyer choice. Multifamily programs,
public facilities and public services. Next slide.
Our general fund revenue overview. You'll see on General
Fund from FY 21, we were just under half
million. And now in FY 23,
we're at 411 six four
from the previous year. That's a reduction of $6,114,
a 1.4% reduction.
Next slide,
expenditures by category. You will
see on the expenditures and we can go by those.
And in purpose of saving time, we'll just look at
FY 23, the proposed It's 135 493
for personnel, 160 for
office rent,
99,084 for restricted accounts
and then other services and charges just over 17,000
for a total again of 411,604.
The next slide is our personnel versus
non personnel. And you will see here that
personnel relates to 33%.
Non personnel is 67% of those dollars.
Next slide. Our general fund
budget expenditures. Again, in order to
save a little time, you can see that previous
year we were 417,718
compared to the current proposed of
411 604. Again a 1.46%
reduction. Next slide.
And the next one on this one is our organization
chart. So you can see the current organization.
To the right, you will see all of the people who report directly
to me. And as of today,
we can add an additional person. Kanesha London is now
my new assistant Director in charge of Compliance.
But that chart to the left is the chart that
represents individual departments who receive
funding and represent employees in those
other departments which total to 88
employees that are funded through us,
along with our 266 employees for
a total of 354 employees.
Next chart. And that chart just gives you some of the
demographics. Let you know that the
department is 39% male, 61% female,
and then the ethnic breakdown of the department.
Next slide our
FY 2023 new awards. This is a breakdown of
the anticipated funding that we will be receiving.
And you can see CDBG. Turs HOPWA
home Emergency shelter. Grant Our
State Homeless Housing Fund and general fund
add up to just over $62 million.
And then you can see the chart. To the right is a breakdown of 40%.
Of that funding is CDBG 18% Hopper,
17% home, 19% Turs,
3% ESG, and then the
Texas Housing bond money is 2%.
And then the general fund dollar is zero
point 66%.
And that is our presentation. Thank you,
Director. And people may be sitting here saying, why do we even do a budget
for a department that has balance or revenue
stream, expense stream of $411,000?
It's because of that last slide. It's because of the flow through.
It's because of all the money that goes from agencies,
whether it's the federal government Glo into your department and
then out. It gives us the opportunity to ask questions of you,
because last time we saw you both together, it wasn't a pretty
picture we were looking at. So I guess my initial question
is how is that going on the Glo side? Because we still
are hearing from residents that even though this is a budget workshop,
411,000 isn't a lot.
But at the same time, I'd like to just get a quick status update
on how things are going, how can
we help your department move things forward and what
do we need to do? So the
gist of it is, the last time we were in front of this committee,
that was just after September 21,
when all things changed in our department. Since then
and at that point when we met, we were having some significant
challenges with the Glo. Some of those challenges have not
totally gone away, but we have a more workable relationship with
the Glo now. We've made some significant progress.
Many of the programs that they put on hold are now starting
to be released and we're moving forward.
Our single family program that the Glo took
back, the only part that the department
kept was the pieces that were still in the pipeline.
That program is now winding down and we anticipate that program will
be completely wound down by mid to late
summer. So we are making some significant improvements.
The multifamily program, which has always been
one of the carrots in our portfolio,
has done extremely well. We have also had
some challenges with the Glo in accepting and moving forward.
We provided them with loads of information so we
can start moving those programs forward. So overall,
we have made some significant improvements. There are some things
some of our programs have been slowed simply because of
primarily the pandemic. Some of those changes are
due to supply chain issues,
a lack of inventory. We have a significant home
down payment, first time Home Buyers Assistance
Program. But the inventory is starting to dry up and
it's very difficult to provide that housing when individuals
can't find it. But we are making some significant
improvements since the last time we've been here. Thank you.
Council Member Abby Cayman. Thank you.
And Director, I really want to congratulate you. You have always
been with the department for your extended tenure,
leading with such dignity,
consistency, and diligence. So thank
you and to your entire staff. I also really want to commend you all.
We've been hearing around the Horseshoe how important
especially, I want to say, with single family homes
in that program and the rebuilding, the flexibility that we have afforded homeowners
that other I will say state agencies have
not afforded that flexibility in
terms of rebuilds and things like that. And I think that's a really big success
story that we are seeing on the ground here. We just did a groundbreaking
halfway kind of checkbox on some
multifamily housing in the district that we're seeing in
real time all of the progress that we're making.
I'm a little concerned, just as we're seeing and Mayor
Pro TEM talked about this, the housing market,
the affordability of housing right now. And with you
saying about that inventory drying up in terms of single family home availability,
a little concerned about that. And we'll submit some questions
through the portal, but I appreciate you raising that. My one
question is, given the constraints that we have as a
city financially, and I'm asking every department this, what are the
needs that are currently not being addressed that you foresee can be a
challenge for the city either near term or
down the road? Well, I think the biggest need is
perhaps asking for additional or more money coming from
general fund. All of the dollars that we typically use
or have available are going to be tied to the federal
government, except for the tourist money. But the tourist money
is already predetermined what we're going to do with that in most
cases. But we have a
tremendous amount of need in the city when it
comes to individuals who need their home repaired.
And because of some of the restrictions that come with
the federal dollar, it becomes very difficult to assist
individuals who are not homeowners.
I am a little bit challenged with trying to assist just renters
in general, because we don't want to enhance a property that
they don't control. And we enhance that property, then the
property owner comes back and either increases their rent or
even worst case scenario, puts them out in order to get more value
for that property. So it becomes very challenging to assist
renters, but we also find ourselves finding
it being very challenging assisting individuals who
can't meet all of the needs, even though they may be the homeowner,
but they don't have everything in place to prove that they're the homeowner.
So they've been in the home for a number of years, may have been
awarded the home through someone's passing,
but they didn't do all of the things necessary to
put the property in their name. So they still technically
cannot prove that they are the homeowner. So it becomes very challenging
when you're trying to use federal dollars to assist those individuals.
That's why it would be better if we had additional general fund dollars
that would be more flexible.
Thank you. We have about ten public
speakers that signed up, so we'll go through the list real quick.
The first we have is Mr. Christopher Rivera,
who is joining us virtually. Christopher star six to unmute.
Hello? Can you hear me? Yes, we can hear you. Great.
Thank you. Housing programs becoming increasingly
important due to the rising costs of living. This year, the Housing and Community
Development Department will only receive 0.1% of the city's general
budget. Local reports indicate rent has gone
up 22% in Houston, and just last week there were 783
Evictions filed. We are facing a housing crisis,
and the city continues to cut funding that keeps our community safe.
In the last ten years, the housing budget has decreased by 82%.
The city of Houston is only one federal budget cut away from
a housing program disaster, an impact that will be felt by low income families
who will lose everything. My questions are,
how will the Housing and Community Development Department work to secure a
self sufficient budget, one that moves away from reliance
on federal funds? Why has the funding for
the Housing Department decreased by 83% in the last ten years?
And why does this department rely so heavily on federal
grants? Thank you. I didn't hear the last
question. Why are we dependent upon federal grants? Was his last comment.
The city of Houston is an entitlement city. We get the majority
of our funding does come from the federal government. Majority of that funding
is coming from HUD. We get funding
through a number of programs, through HUD CDBG, which is our
normal funding source. We also have home. We also
have ESG programming.
That has always been the way the department has been set up and the way
the city has been set up to receive funding from HUD.
The dollar amount that we receive is based on a formula that
has been preset. That formula was
designed in the late 60s, early 70s.
That number has been the same, and we have not been able to
get her to deviate from the current formula.
Even though we are growing in size and have grown in size since
the original formula
was created, it has not adjusted anywhere in the country.
And there are some cities who are not as large as us receive much
more funding than we do. But it was based on the formula and amount of
need that those cities had at that time.
We've inquired, we've asked, but the
formula has not yet been changed.
I don't have a really good answer about how
to get an increase in
funding from the city. We can ask for additional
general fund dollar, but that is a budget issue.
That is always going to be a budget issue.
Sorry, go ahead. When it comes
to assisting individuals that were facing eviction,
we are currently dealing with some funding that we did have that
is dealing with individuals who are in the midst of being evicted
at the present time.
Great. Thank you.
In person, Mr. Jason oliver.
Hi director bynum thank you for your presentation.
First, I noticed, and there was a recent county
report that basically showed that we have almost none of
the necessary supply for what's described as extremely low
income, zero to 30% median household
income housing. Is the department set up to even
shift that severe
need at all? Yeah,
that's my first question. I missed
the beginning of your question where you said you saw the statistics
that came that said what? So there is a
severe shortage in the supply for extremely low income,
like zero to 30% median household income housing,
and we're just in no way equipped to provide to
meet that need and that demand in the near future.
Well, we are trying to meet the demand in
a number of ways. It's very difficult in single
family ownership. We do try to do a
better job in trying to meet it in the rental market. So we are
trying to provide that in a number of opportunities by
preventing or asking all of our developers to look at an
array of income
structures so we can provide rental
units for all of the streams of income
in the city. It is very difficult because there is a large
pool in that group versus the number of units
that we can put on the market. Okay. And then
this is, I guess, a question for council, because you've come here saying
that you need the time has expired, which council members
are supportive of an amendment to allocate more general funds
for the housing department so that you can address the issues that you talked about
before. Thank you. Thank you.
Baba Blandy.
Hi, good afternoon. I'll start by reiterating Jason's questions
and use my time to answer that. And I also
want to follow up on Christopher's question.
And a lot of times I've come up here and asked, like, what could you
do with more? But I'm actually curious. It was
very shocking to me that in ten years, your budget has dropped
by 83%. You went from almost 2.5.
The next year was like, 1.4, and then it dropped to like,
677. And then even in the past seven years, it's been reduced by 38%.
And I'm just curious, how has this impacted you all's ability to
provide for the city of Houston?
I know, like, what can we do to increase the housing department resources to
meet the needs. I know you've mentioned increasing the general fund budget, so I'm going
to circle that back to Jason's question. What council
members are open to a budget amendment to give our city what we
need? Because you don't need
to be here 2 seconds before you see how many people are unhoused.
And we know how insane the housing market is here.
So, Director, isn't it true that we
have additional dollars that your department utilizes for housing
that's outside of just the general budget, federal dollars,
state dollars, grant dollars that are just not encompassed
in your presentation today? That is correct. We would
also have access to the tourist dollars. And the tourist
dollars are designed
to help with the development of affordable
housing. Can we go back to slide twelve?
Sorry, Council Member Pollard, is it okay if I just track real quick
to what you asked? Well, let me get his response
to this. I just want to clarify where
all of the resources that your
department is utilizing for housing needs within the city of Houston,
and on page twelve, you have a breakdown here of different
funding sources. Can you elaborate a little bit more on that?
So you'll see on the breakdown on the housing sources,
sure. Everyone realizes that the majority of our dollars come
from CDBG funding. That's our largest pot of the pie,
$25 million. And then you see Turs 12 million,
hopper is 10 million. And we can go on and
on. What you are presenting today
is just the general fund. That's all we're presenting today is a general
fund piece of the budget. And your follow up? Well,
Councilman Pollard, I understand those funding revenues,
but what concerns me is that ten years ago, their general fund budget
was almost $2.5 million. And it paid as our city
grows and as our housing prices skyrocket,
that our city budget is being reduced so drastically.
But the question I would have, and we can get this from the department and
then get it back out to the public, is how much money were
we getting from outside sources as well to supplement?
If we were at 2.5 million before, what were we getting in CDBG?
What were we getting in Turs? Dollars. Because that plays a role also
in, I think, how we allocate dollars from the general fund.
So if you can work on that, Director, to show
maybe ten years ago what was coming
in from a funding standpoint from outside the city as
compared to now, sure, we can get that information to you. Now,
I can tell you, I've been in the department for 30 years. When I first
got to the permanent CDBG, funding at that time for the
city was over $60 million.
But as they began to get additional municipalities
join the group, as the need grew
around the country, then the dollars, they're just
limited dollars. So the dollars start coming down council
Member Alcorn thank you, Chair. In other cities,
do they operate in the same way with most of the money coming
into their departments being from the federal sources? Our local
dollars are of course the Tours dollars are coming into it.
Or do other cities within Texas spend more
general fund money? They tend
to give their department a little bit more general fund dollars.
We've seen cities outside of Texas who really do
give a larger contribution from
their general fund to the Housing department.
Philadelphia stands out, los Angeles
and a few others, I believe chicago, they tend to dedicate
more general fund dollar to the department. Thank you.
Council Member Thomas staff.
Hi. So Council
Member Thomas just wanted to express that we have an annual
action plan that's outlined to support homelessness and
all federal allocations. And in response to your question,
the reduction of general fund money is because positions and programs
were attached to federal money to leave the general fund.
So that's her note. Thank you. Okay,
I appreciate you all's time. Sakunda Joseph.
Hello, I'm Sakonda Joseph. Like wakanda.
But thank you for your presentation.
I had other questions, but I just think it's an opportunity to make
a statement is that I do want the council members here to know,
which I know that you do that right now, the city of Houston is number
one in evictions, number two in folks
not having access to affordable housing. Many people who came,
a few people who had came here earlier today were people who missed work,
left early. Some people couldn't come because of work because
they are in trouble. I get calls on my own phone
about the evictions, and since February,
I've been so stressed just as a human being here,
living in this city that care about the people that are in
this city, until I'm trying to figure out what it is that we
can do to do better. So I don't want you all to look over what
was said. If there's opportunity to if the budget has
decreased over ten years, for what this?
For what we can do, right? We understand. The federal stuff
aside, I really hope that folks that are elected by
the people take the time out, because I'm taking my time
out to think about what we can do to increase
the budget to make sure that a lot of our citizens are
housed and have a safe place to say thank you. Thank you.
Carrie Colleague I
just want to thank you for your presentation and
I'm just going to read my question. According to the Kinder Institute,
evictions cost Harris County over 240,000,000 a
year prior to the economic impacts of COVID-19.
Harris county and the city of Houston are not direct
comparisons, but there is a lot of overlap.
And I want to know what does your department propose as solutions to
address Houston's eviction crisis
similar to what Sakanda said, we have a lot of people that are being
evicted. And I know that you stated that you
need more funds. So my
ask is that City council would propose
redistributing some of those funds to specifically
housing so that we can address that situation.
And then my second question would be okay,
finish your second question really quick. It's just about repairs
and just funding for single home repairs and
rebuild. We have a lot of people that, even after
Harvey, are still struggling to fix
their homes. And although there are some programs I
recently called as soon as a month ago, and my aunt
specifically, they were told they had no funds in the city
to help rebuild her home.
Let me ask you your first question. In terms of the
dollars that came into the city to assist individuals
who were going through the eviction process.
We were able to serve between it was a joint venture
between us and the county. We were able to provide assistance
to over 70,000 families and
put out nearly $400 million
in one year. We were able to do that,
but the need was so much greater. Correct.
And we just did not
have any more dollars. We put out all the dollars
that we had and the dollars that came in remaining
that we got from areas
that did not spend those dollars. We put that for individuals
who were in eviction as we speak.
So we eliminated rental assistance and
went directly to individuals who were in the
process of going through eviction as we speak. So that's
where those dollars are, but we just don't have any
additional now we've asked for additional funding.
That funding just has not arrived. Thank you.
And her second question, the second part of your question. When it comes to repair,
again, the dollars are limited. We can only do what
we can. It is a very difficult
product in dealing with home repair.
As I mentioned earlier, one of the major issues
with dealing with home repair are the individuals who cannot prove that they
are the owner. We have our hands
tied with being able to provide assistance to individuals
who are renting. So it is a very challenging
process in getting those done. The difference between what we did
versus what the Glo did was the Glo takes
the list and if you're up next, if you're ready to go,
then you get service. But if you're not
ready to go, if you don't have title and you
don't have all your ducks lined up in a row
ready to receive assistance, then they move on. What the
City of Houston approach is,
we try not to leave anyone behind. So we have volunteer
lawyers. We try to put everyone
into a process that allows them to get
a complete service. Not just are you ready
to be served? If you don't comply today,
then you just miss out. We're really trying to do everything we
can to not leave anyone behind that becomes
very challenging and it does become very time consuming.
And we're doing that with limited dollars. Thank you.
Julia ardua.
Thank you, sir, for your presentation. I also want to say I stand in
solidarity with all five people that spoke before
me. I'd like to ask which council members
are supportive of an amendment during
this cycle to allocate more general funds to housing?
I think that's really important then to you,
sir. I'd like to ask, has the department examined eviction rights
to council programs as seen in other cities?
If so, what would be the cost to provide that legal
representation to histonians facing eviction?
Could you repeat that question? Yes, sir.
I'll take my mask up. Has the department
examined eviction rights to council programs as
seen in other cities? If so,
what would be the cost to provide that
legal representation to Houstonians facing eviction?
We have not looked at what other cities are doing, but we are
providing legal services to individuals now.
Okay. And is there a cost to those citizens?
There is no cost to those citizens. We're footing that cost.
Okay. Thank you, sir. Broderick Butler.
Director, thank you very much for your presentation. Again,
I apologize that I'm not going to speak to you. I'm going to speak
through you again. We're in a situation of
calling a thing a thing. The city of Houston,
and I won't say that it's in bad faith,
but I will call it disingenuous that outwardly
the city promotes housing as a
priority, as something to champion.
But when you look at the real where the rubber meets the
road, math is math.
So I don't know what to tell you other than that. So I
find it very disheartening that the
citizens of this city and those that are moving here
and those that live here and those that have come and told you what
the reality is.
I'm at a loss for words. And again, I don't use the
word bad faith or lack of good faith. I genuinely
use the word disingenuous.
You put your money where your mouth is. Your money is what your priorities
are. And I think that this
is just a bad deal. So that's all
I got to say about that.
Well, just one comment.
We are very understanding and we sympathize about
all of the issues. And we do understand it would
be great if we could help each and every individual that needs
assistance. There's a lot of people in this city that need assistance.
We just don't have the resources to do it.
Even if we got an abundance amount of money
from general fund, it still would not be enough
to have a significant impact on all the
individuals in this city. And we are trying to do the best
we can by leveraging the dollars that we have in order
to have the greatest impact. Well. Thank you, Director. I think
I speak for all of us when we say that we understand that you all
are doing the best that you can with the resources that you have. The city
of Houston has priorities all across the board, from solid
waste to public safety to housing to parks to libraries
to airports to you name it. This is a city with over 2 million people
with a limited budget. If you have $5 billion and
you take from one department, you have to give to another. And so we're trying
to find ways in which to allocate dollars in a fair and equitable
manner, but also trying to make sure that we reach
the necessary needs of all Houstonians.
There's those that may feel like we should put more money in housing and take
more money away from a different department,
and then you have those who say that we need
more money in a different department to take away from another department.
So you're always going to have to have a balance. And that's
why you elect us to try to listen to your concerns,
which we do. And we thank all of you all for coming forward to present
those, but it's still a balance that we have to fit.
And I think your department does an excellent job of trying to
do the best you can with the dollars that you have. And I
want you all to know that directly from us as well.
There are no additional public speakers. This includes our housing
department workshop. We will now adjourn the housing department budget
workshop.